A UN-brokered peace conference for Yemen scheduled for later this week...
...appears in doubt as Yemeni officials say the talks have been postponed.
In Iraq, thousands of displaced people from violence in Ramadi...
...continue to flee to Baghdad.
In Burundi, protests resume in the capital Bujumbura against President Pierre Nkurunziza,...
...after the funeral of the slain opposition leader.
In Malaysia, authorities exhume human remains after finding 139 grave sites...
...in suspected trafficking camps near their border with Thailand.
And finally from Tunisia, a soldier opens fire on colleagues...
...at a military base in the capital,...
...killing three and wounding 15 before being shot dead.